so
republic book nine begins in the middle
of a conversation
that you don't actually have unless
you've read book eight
and book eight was about all these
different
types of personalities so if you've got
these three parts of the souls with the
rational art and spirited part
you know how do these get out of whack
with each other there's
there's different regimes in plato
in the republic and to the regimes
correspond different kinds of people
so his best republic is the one where
the people who are the guardians who
spend all their time you know
learning about how the how things work
and you know
they enjoy learning they are the ones
who run the show
philosopher kings and then the
auxiliaries are the lesser guardians
the police the firefighters all the
people who have to have courage
are you know enforcing the role of the
guardians
and then you've got everybody else this
big mass of craftspeople
all the other people doing things
ranging from
those who farm to those who
beautify to those who make music pick
anything you like
plato thinks that the rational part
should
rule over these parts should tell them
what to do
and the spirited part should enforce the
rule so what happens when these things
get out of whack
well it's sort of like what happens with
societies so
this part is really about getting honor
or we don't use the word honor so much
we talk about respect
or pride or being in charge
right this is the competitive part of us
too
we're not competing because we just want
you know the object of the competition
we want the glory that comes with it
right
now what happens when this part is is in
charge
and uses the rational part just to get
what it wants and it's still keeping the
appetites in check
then you have what he he calls
something like an aristocracy but it's
not completely an aristocracy it's about
honor so he calls it a democracy
and you can imagine people like this
not just political regimes where say the
military's in charge
right but um and the scientists are
helping the military
but people are like that you all know
people who are particularly driven
they tend to be fairly honorable right
they tend not to indulge their appetites
too much because they've got big goals
but they they may not be thinking
through
whether those goals really are what they
ought to be striving for
so they tend to get themselves into
trouble over time
that's a fairly honorable way of living
according to plato
but it's going to lead eventually to
lower and lower conditions
and then you're going to have cases
where the appetite part gets
gets really uh to be in charge the next
thing
the next kind of regime that he talks
about is the oligarchy and i think you
guys have heard that term right
we say oligarchy what comes to mind
the term really means rule by the few
what how do we use it
remember the wall street occupy wall
street protests against the oligarchs
the one percent what makes the one
percent the one percent it's not that
they are the most honorable people
what makes them the one percent yeah
yeah so
money gives them power gives them
influence
they can buy some some respect but um
the occupy wall street movement if there
was any coherence to it part of it was
you know a reaction against the one
percent
running the show now when when the rich
run the show it's called
an oligarchy and
um rich people when it comes to
to money and power what do they what do
they tend to want
what is their their main goals
there could be a variety right some rich
people actually want to make the world a
better place
so they start foundations like uh you
know after bill gates made a ton of
money
um he and his wife established the bill
and melissa gates foundation and they
digested themselves a lot of their
wealth
they're still you know
astronomically wealthy compared to us
right
but um they put a lot of involvement
it's a good use
all these foundations the ford
foundation carnegie foundation they've
done a lot of great things right
um is that always how how the rich
use you know their wealth the mechanics
of things
what else do they do
try to get richer right um
and one way to be richer is to screw
everyone else
right say forget you i'm not paying you
a lot of money
as a matter of fact if i can get out of
the contracts with you i'm not going to
pay you at all
and you don't become rich by rip by
living life a rich person you become
rich by
by holding on to as much as you can and
trying to get as much as you can
and so the oligarchical person tends to
be kind stingy
they tend in their in their soul they
want things
but they're more interested in the
acquisition than in the enjoyment you
might say
so they tend to be kind of stirring now
the
plato picks this up at this point in
book nine it talks about the democratic
person and i'm going to just give you a
sort of thumbnail sketch of that
if oligarchy is about riches democracy
is about freedom
about getting to do what you like one
definition of democracy that the ancient
greeks had didn't have anything to do
with voting
it had to do with the fact that in a
democracy anybody gets to say and do
whatever
whatever they want to so long as they
don't kill somebody here you know
but you know burning up acropolis down
or things like that
destroy the tri-ring fleet disrupt the
chorus
there are laws against all sorts of
things but the idea was you had
you had a license you had electrotherapy
which meant freedom
you had parasia which means the capacity
to say whatever you like
and the democratic person is kind of
more laid back
than the oligarchical person they're
both motivated ultimately by their
appetites these are two different
modes of serving the appetites so as the
article person is trying to hold on to
things and get more and more of it
the democratic person is like hey those
money's for spending
let's have a good time and plato talks
about that person
getting drawn into all sorts of
activities by
companions who are really into
indulging themselves and
you know so think about kids going off
to college right you guys are all
juniors
you've seen you went through
freshman year you've seen other kids go
through it
what typically happens when kids leave
particularly when they leave
fairly strict households when they go
off to college
yeah you go insane yeah
and in what way i mean that's sort of in
general drinking
partying yeah and those are the things
that plato's calling the appetites you
know
we like to drink alcohol because it
makes us feel good
you know it's why people take drugs too
because drugs make people feel good
um they're not good for you but what are
you gonna say no i was gonna say
that they would basically just kind of
cut loose
yeah do whatever they want sometimes
they wind up in trouble with you know
with grades because of that
um you know plato didn't know about
video games but
if you get really into a video game that
could like shoot your whole first
semester right i've seen that happen to
some students
eating they think about the freshman 15.
up in the culinary it's called the
freshman 30.
um because you know we're eating rich
food right um
but you see people go through that if
you don't have restrictions
and you haven't learned how to place
restrictions on yourself and the people
around you are saying hey let's have a
good time
it's easy to get into that sort of stuff
can you have to do with dating sexual
relationships all those are matters of
the appetite part of the soul
so the democratic person eventually
swings back
and i think you guys have seen that sort
of stuff right how many of you actually
like your freshman year you you didn't
go completely hog wild because you
didn't wouldn't be here
now right but uh you know you indulge
yourself quite a bit
and then you kind of swung back and now
you you're more on track
only one person yeah okay that's more
a little more realistic yeah um
and we all actually i did that too um
and i hadn't even been in the army
before i went to college i should have
known better um
but it is fairly natural the democratic
person has a strict parent
and they find a happy media between the
strict parent and these these other
people
who are like just totally self-indulgent
and probably getting themselves in lots
of trouble
the tyrannical person comes about
later on instead of having the strict
oligarchical parent who's you know
giving them rules and saying don't spend
your money on that sort of thing
think about your future they've got this
happy-go-lucky democratic parent who's
much more relaxed
and so when they they go off on their
own
and they run into all these companions
who are all about
totally indulging themselves there's not
as much to swing back to
and so the tyrannical person is also
going to be all about this appetite part
of the soul
but what's going to happen as plato
describes it
is um there is there's something that's
sort of like
injected into them there's the
metaphor that he uses he says imagine
the same thing that happened to the son
who's
that's already happened the father is
drawn into a perfectly lawless life no
lawless means without rules without
structure
and you know you can imagine what that's
like um
by your seducers this is term perfect
liberty perfect freedom getting to do
what you want to do
it's often held up as an ideal for us um
his father and friends take part with
his moderate desires so you know when he
wants to like go to the movies or
hang out and go fishing you know his
dad's there for that his mom's there for
that
but when it comes to like you know the
the drinking party
that goes on for two days or um
you know going off to to get drugs or
going off to vegas and you know just
trying every single thing that you could
possibly try you know
um his dad's not going to come along for
that ride
it's going to be all these other people
and as that happens like he says
they can try to implant him a master
passion a master
desire a master appetite to be lord over
his idol and spend thrift
lusts so what does he really want
to
and how's this going to work
well i mean there's nothing like
intrinsically
terrible about indulging yourself once
in a while as a matter of fact you
probably
should or you're going to go nuts but if
you want to indulge yourself
all the time if your main goal in life
is to just indulge
every appetite and desire that you have
you're going to start running into
problems and plato traces out this whole
story
of sort of you know decline and fall of
this kind of person
so um i'm going to skip over you know
whether he's like like a drunk or stuff
like that
so he says how does this person live so
there's gonna be feasts
and corrals and rumblings and courtesans
now that's fancy language for he's gonna
go out drinking and drinking awful lot
and
you know in our society probably try
some some hard drugs
and there'll be some some uh
prostitutes involved and
let's see rubblings parties
imagine charlie sheen he's going to live
a charlie sheen
he's been out of the news for a while
because he's managed to stay out of
trouble
but you know that sort of level of
self-indulgence that's what this person
is after
and um what happens next
now imagine that you were gonna do that
and not just to you that's in college
right now who actually has to
you know turn in papers and do
internships
and that sort of business imagine it's
that you
five years from now you are already
in your your first real job that you had
out of college and you've managed to
rise up a couple
ranks what happens if you do that and
not just on vacation
yeah everything's gonna get screwed up
yeah it's gonna screw up your
relationships most likely
and friends will start saying what the
hell is wrong with you
what's the real big problem what are you
going to run out of
money money yeah you need money
in order to buy all those sorts of
fun things you know just think about it
plato is talking about the appetites the
appetites have to do with
eating drinking sex
entertainment rest those sorts of things
if you want to eat fancy meals you have
to spend a lot of money
don't you even if you make them yourself
you got to buy fancy ingredients
those cost quite a bit there's this
great spoof article out you know that
just started going around the internet
about this woman their terrible
experience at whole foods
have any of you seen this yeah yeah
google it and it's really quite funny um
she ends up like spending 300 bucks for
one shopping trip what if you're going
to do that you better have a good job
especially if you want to if you want to
pair those dishes with fine lines
you can spend a lot of money on wine you
can even spend a lot of money on beer
if you like fancy beer right i don't
know who foster cheap one
yeah cheap wine yeah but this guy
doesn't want cheap wine he wants the
best of it you know
he wants the top label stuff um
sooner or later this guy's gonna run out
of money then what's gonna happen
is he's gonna say oh man i really need
to cut back
probably he's gonna go to a narcissistic
deep credit card debt right
because credit cards allow us to spend
way more than we actually have
um big big problem for for my generation
and for your generation
they love to get students into credit
card debt
um
what happens when you reach the limit
you could just say that's it i gotta cut
back on this sort of stuff
is this person equipped to do that why
not
why couldn't they just like through
force of will saying cold turkey
no more yeah that's their life at this
point so if they can't buy it they'll
probably steal it
or find some other way to get it yeah
this part of their soul
has become the main thing
man think of it in terms of muscles then
you've ever seen these guys
who like totally bulk up the top part of
their body and they don't work out their
lower body
and because their their lower body may
actually be in fairly good shape
but because the top is so bulked up they
look really weird
they're misformed really um
it's like that these parts of the soul
atrophy if you don't use your
your reason and part of the part of the
function of reason is actually to say
hey this is good for me this is bad for
me
i should think about this i should you
know imagine the consequences
if you don't do that sort of thing is
that easy to do once
you actually need to do it no because
you haven't worked out that
intellectual muscle likewise the
spirited part of the soul
this is really where your force of will
lies the capacity to say
no to yourself or to push yourself to do
things that are difficult
if you haven't done that is that easy to
do
no it's easy to go after what you want
though and then you're right you
probably have to
steal it or plato actually goes through
a whole list
of things you know this guy is going to
pray on on who first
the random passerby
their family this is one of the things
that actually makes
addiction so difficult is addicts behave
like this tyrannical person
and they prey first on those who are
close to them
which tends to take off those people who
are close to them and make it very
difficult for them to
be a support network for them when they
want to quit being addicts
but this guy is is rapidly alienating
everybody begins with his family
and first he you know just cheats them
imagine somebody like taking money out
of
their mom's purse or their dad's wallet
late at night you know
and then that's not going to go on that
that long though
but eventually you know they're going to
start saying where's the money going
what are you doing with this
so he will as he says tyrannize over
tyranny
is based on
3s
the tyrant keeps control over other
people and attains what they want
ultimately by force by fraud
or by appear and
that's not going to be a very happy life
the tiger thinks that they're really
having the happiest life because they're
getting to indulge themselves
but you know if you look at it closely
they're not happy at all um
so he talks about them taking the the
property and then and then
you know pretty soon mom and dad are out
of money so where are you gonna go after
that
other people so like he says um
he breaks into a house or steals the
garments of some nightly wayfarer
that sort of theft is not as common
these days except for shoes i think
or jackets um but it was quite common to
reach
next he proceeds to clear a temple we
don't generally steal from temples
i suppose it does happen that churches
and mosques are broken into from time to
time
but temples were sort of like the
important cultural centers for the greek
type
so imagine if somebody
stole all of the money out of the paris
accounts marist goes drunk
that would be the sort of thing that
they're talking about um
and eventually you know he leads all
sorts of things he talks about some of
them becoming you know bodyguards or
mercenary soldiers
then they become thieves burglars cut
purses foot pads robbers of temples
and then we talked about man steelers
what do you think man steelers means
kidnappers why do people kidnap other
people
just just for the sheer fun of it
yeah that was a big thing to sell them
back
in our days we also have the sex drive
the entire sex
uh human trafficking sex trade would all
be based on
this sort of thing you know if you're
doing human trafficking
buying and selling people that's part of
what he's talking about is man stealers
then he also talks if they're if they're
able to speak well they they turn in
formers informers were people in ancient
greece
who would um sort of like spy on other
people and give
information to the authorities to try to
get them into trouble
so if you you think of them as sort of
like private investigators
um for evil you know not all private
investigators are
bad um but these guys were uh bear false
witness perjuring
themselves in law of course and taking
bribes
those are the sorts of things that will
get you money
but notice all of them are unjust
right
does this person know that they're
committing injustice
what do you think plato's not really
clear about that
think about people that you know that
are
sort of moving along that trajectory
that they know what they're doing
is wrong yeah i think at first they like
but then they start to develop just
denial
and turns into like
that's fact for them it's no longer
yeah eventually you're the jerk for
pointing it out to them right you're
you're the unjust person who won't leave
them alone when they're just trying to
make a buck or
you know protect themselves or yeah i
think a lot of times they're very
focused on themselves they don't realize
how their actions are impacting the
people around them
so like the injustice would be against
people but they can't
realize it there's also injustice in
inside of them too that they don't want
a lot of times people like this don't
know themselves really very well
um it's you know plato talks about
them driving out the old good opinions
that they might have gotten from their
parents or from other cultural sources
they don't want to hear you know they
wouldn't want to read plato republic
book 9
right somebody like like this would say
why are you bothering me with this earth
are you trying to lay a guilt trip on me
that sort of thing
um he also talks about them driving out
good appetites
and it's not entirely clear with what he
means by that but
that's the tyrannical person now the
question is
are they happy in some respects it looks
like they could be because they're
getting to do whatever they want
is that really making them happy is it a
happy life
plato raises the stakes he says what
about if somebody like this gets to be
in charge
now have any of you had
terrible bosses that have jobs that
you've worked
i remember calling one of my bosses a
tin pot tiger
and at one time i used to be kind of
loose with what i would say
you know didn't think very much about it
it was much more driven by my spirit
than
an intellect um
have you ever got a bad boss because
it's just like you know you're always
wrong they're always right
they're always coming down on you
they're trying to get they're trying to
get everything they can out of here but
maybe they're a tyrannical person
the um the tyrants you could have a
tyrannical relationship you could you
could have a
group boyfriend or girlfriend or spouse
who's really a tyrant and that would get
miserable existence as well
um or you know your group of friends
could be unfortunately dominated by
entities in which case they're not
really friends so much um
you guys have seen that movie mean girls
um
the one i forget all the names of them
the one who's on top at the start
wasn't it she's the tyrant
she's always undermining the other ones
she's trying to keep them all in place
she's mean to everybody else around
right she's a tyrant and then
the the big story is of course is
lindsay lohan's character
comes in and is gonna like you know
she's gonna
unseat her she becomes a tyrant in the
process as well
and then she you know her friend points
it out to her and she doesn't want to
hear it but then it's really true
and you know she's supposed to learn
something in the process well that's
sort of like
the tyrant coming back to you know a
good state but most of the time that
doesn't happen right
um tyrannical people are
sort of stuck where they are and once
they have power that might makes right
theory that we looked at that's what
they're going to use they're in charge
whatever they say goes if you don't like
it they're going to use
something against you
they get to have whatever it is that
their appetites tell them
to to pursue don't they because they're
the boss
and plato asks the question again are
they happy
why not why is it not a happy existence
they're getting everything they want
they want a
massage you know at three o'clock in the
morning
from the white house chief of staff
white house chief of staff has to do
what they want you know if they decide
they want uh
uh you know a big thing of m m's with
all the green ones taken out
that's what they get some musicians have
had that as like riders in their
contracts believe it or not so why
aren't they happy
yeah because if they have that kind of
personality without
wanting something from somebody else
they're really satisfied yeah
their their appetites have grown so
strong that even though they're able to
be satisfied for a moment they're not
able to be satisfied
for long yeah maybe even methods like
through
which they're getting their happiness
you know force fraud and fear
they're not really a genuine action from
anybody that they're
seeing like a true response from anybody
yeah plato says that at one point the
tyrant
has to treat everybody as either masters
or slaves they're not able to have
friends
but you know even if they have family
members with family members it's always
a subordinate or
a superior relationship it's not a
relationship of equals who actually want
to be with each other
is there any other reason can they
actually do what they want completely
can somebody who lives like this and
uses you know
fraud forcing fear on other people can
they just go out
if they want to go to a concert and they
go to the concert
can they go to the ball game can they go
to the party
i mean in a way they can how do people
like that go
can they just go by themselves hang out
why not
because they have to take the people
that they're busy forcing to do things
for them
with them they're their clients or
did you ever handle that no i was just
going to say like they're always going
to have something to say about it like
always complaining about something like
there's that something out of it maybe
they actually want to like be in charge
of nero
would stage these uh these musical
things then he'd you know
he'd have to play his piece and then of
course everyone awesome so wonderful
um they have to worry about what other
people are going to do
if they were to go out on the town
without a bodyguard
and they've been abusing everybody
somebody's going to pop them in the face
or do much worse somebody will stab them
or
shoot them or something like that or
even just you know
insult them you know
ball of mud at them and they they can't
take that
so they really can't live the kind of
life that they want
the other thing that's particularly bad
about this is
not only is the tyrant unhappy who
probably deserves to be unhappy how's
everybody else doing
in this sort of city
the suck-ups do okay so long as they
stay on the right side of the tyrant
but everybody else especially those who
actually have good character
and who might say hey i don't want to
you know be part of this this thing that
you're doing
um they might get killed they might lose
all of their property this this happened
quite often in ancient greece and rome
so the tyrants
either as a state or as a person
turns out not to be happy at all
you might say well why do people why do
people live this sort of life then why
why do they aim for this sort of thing
well it has to do with these parts of
the soul and which parts have been
indulged and which parts have been
neglected
and you know the tyrant is really when
it comes to the spirited part
a coward they rely on other people
ultimately to do all of their
stuff they're a fool folly is the
opposite of prudence
when it comes to the rational part of
the soul they're intemperate
they are unable to control their
appetites for pleasures
and because all these things are out of
whack and the appetite part is running
the show
they're unjust and so their injustice
will flow from
the injustice outside will flow from the
injustice inside
and they will probably make a lot of
other people unjust in the process
so that's that's the whole thing about
the tyrannical person
it's good when we're doing virtue ethics
not just to look at
how we ought to be but how we ought not
to be
and why what's so bad about being that
kind of person
plato thinks that we often get mistaken
about about desires
and and pleasures i actually should have
left this
this part this stuff up
national spirited
and
the next thing that he talks about is
each one of these
having desires
and having distinctive pleasures
and being tied in with a sort of way of
life
um what is it
that the rational part of the soul
really wants
just to like you know tell everybody
what to do all the time
not really yeah winston
yeah um he talks about his distinctive
good being truth but then he also talks
about wisdom
learning
for every one of you there is something
that you enjoy learning
it may not be philosophy that's okay you
know i don't expect everybody to share
the same things
even among philosophers we're not always
interested in the same thing a lot of
people like reading plato
you know um but there are some things
you do want to learn about even if it's
just like the box scores
or the latest fashion or things like
that
you're learning something about
something right
and every one of you has to figure out
how you're going to run your life so you
have to use the rational part
to some extent at least you know figure
out how to how to
arrange your lifestyles to achieve the
goods that you want but these are the
distinctive goods
you know college is actually supposed to
be about
this stuff getting rich is is
a nice side product of college getting a
great job
with a nice side product but the reason
why we actually have colleges and
universities is because
people like to learn and otherwise you
wouldn't have any professors
we don't get into this for money you
know um
i mean maybe somebody does but they're
totally
stupid if they think they're gonna make
it rich as a professor
because there's so many other ways to
make a million um
what is this part one
because the spirited agitated part of
our soul he says this is the part with
which we get angry
yeah let's honor and again this is one
of those terms that we have to translate
we don't talk about honor that much yeah
just like general quality to your
personality
are these general qualities are you
asking or yeah as i'm saying
like what type of person you are well
these are yeah it's a good question
these are gonna make the the person the
kind of person that they are
but each one of them could be done well
or done done poorly
hold on to that thought and we'll move
into that in a moment so
let's think about honor for a minute we
don't talk about honor that much
when somebody is um held up above
other people how do we talk about that
yeah
like respect respect is a word prestige
you guys use that term um
i think a lot of people who want
celebrity want this sort of thing
he also talks about this part of the
soul wanting
victory which really means wanting
success
and it's also a part that likes to be in
charge likes to be over other people
um likes to you know be the boss
but it wants to be the boss because it's
the best you know
what about the appetite part now plato
here
he makes a move that you might not agree
with i actually think it's a little
questionable myself but he's
he's making it for simplicity's sake
we've talked about what the appetites
want they want things like eating
whenever you want to
right what kinds of foods do we really
like um
do we really like healthy foods
sometimes some healthy foods but what
are the three ingredients
or three tastes that tend to make food
so delectable
salt right sugar
sweet and
spicy no we like spicy yeah and spicy is
usually good for you
what about fat you take the fat content
out things don't taste the same
replace it with that fat substitute
stuff and you have all sorts of good
side effects
um the appetites would like to just eat
as much as you they possibly could
just stuff yourself completely full same
thing with like drinking
you know um and you're not necessarily
drinking alcohol think about drinking
soda soda tastes pretty good right
because it's sweet
it's got taste there's some soda that
you like how much of it should you drink
a day
not too much right if you drink a 12
pack of coke a day
that would be really bad for you because
you know just
put a penny in coke sometimes and watch
how the tarnish goes on
because of the acid in it sex
can can our desires for sex sometimes
you know go overboard
and get us into trouble and get us into
all sorts of situations that are
probably not good for us
yeah we make movies about this comedies
and tragedies right and dramas um
you know there's a whole bunch of things
now plato says
what we're going to talk about here is
not those things
it's going to be wealth why well
yeah because you can just get all those
things with money exactly so wealth
leads to
pleasures and you know some people
actually do and uh
sort of losing sight of the connection
between these that wealth is a means to
money and they desire wealth for its own
sake
okay so there are some people who desire
to say that
so plato's going to treat these these
things in these terms
now there's pleasures that come with
this there is a pleasure
in in learning um is all learning
pleasant to you
not even all pleasant to me and i'm a
college professor there's some things i
i read and i'm like oh my god is this
boring
actually there's there's i hate to say
this but there's some people
whose texts i'm going to be inflicting
on you later this semester
who you are not going to be reading them
for their literary
value or style you're going to be
reading them for the ideas that are in
them
but you know bentham and kant they are
not
great stylists um they are kind of a
chore to read
there's pleasure in the ideas in
learning the ideas but there's not
pleasure in
their the way that they're arranged but
there's other things that you know we we
all enjoy
learning to some degree um do we enjoy
being honored by other people is that
pleasurable
yeah we human beings like that we like
to have other people look up to us
particularly if we're deserving of it
then it really
feels good if we're not deserving of it
then we're always like
i'm not sure if i should take this award
or not you know maybe i don't completely
deserve it
but you know as long as we think that
we're deserving of it we really enjoy
this
what about wealth do you do you like
when you open the birthday card and
there's a you know
20 bill in it does that feel good
now you don't actually sit there and
think to yourself
aha i have wealth now i can purchase for
myself pleasures
you know you probably don't even think
automatically that
now i can buy this one thing that i
wanted that'll give me pleasure
you're just you're happy you got the 20
bill um
what if somebody gave you a 20 euro note
instead of a 20 bill
how would you react to that it's worth a
little bit more
by the way than a 20 bill
because the euro is stronger than the
dollar right now
you wouldn't care right you'd be like
what the hell is with this fake money
because you can't buy anything with it
over here um
but we do you know we do desire well
there's a pleasure involved in
contemplating it
when you guys have retirement accounts
later on you'll find yourself every once
in a while checking out and be like yeah
cool i got some money in there that's
that's great you know
um and the pleasures that we you know
want to buy with
well we know that those are pleasant
right so we have pleasures all up and
down this
this range here's the question you can
ask
which of them is actually the most
pleasant now each of these
if you pursue them leads to a different
kind of life
there's the life of the philosopher or i
think we would probably see the life of
the intellectual the person who is
pursuing
intellectual goods there's the person
who is pursuing
um goods of you know respect honor the
honor seeker the ambitious person
he talks about the soldier but could we
imagine a lot of other people
involved in that sort of thing i think
so you know people who want to be
managers
maybe they don't want to make a ton of
money they actually want to be in charge
of an organization
if you are thinking about becoming an
entrepreneur i think that's probably
this part of your soul that's that's
real excited about that
um appetite part of the soul what is it
like when
that is the primary thing then you're a
wealth seeker
and you're a wealth seeker because you
want to be able to buy nice things and
enjoy them
so whose life is actually the most
pleasant is the question plato
deals with this by looking at
um two different things at first
what is what he calls the
right criterion and then experience
so what we can experience first
by show of hands how many of you have
enjoyed learning
now it's not surprising that almost all
of you are raising your hands because
it's a college classroom right
if you didn't enjoy learning at all
where would you more likely be right now
working not at school no help the
workforce
maybe you've gone to a vocational school
instead
got an apprenticeship you know
apprentices actually have to learn a lot
too though
it's just you know craft knowledge um
have you all of you like held to office
at one time or at least excelled in
something
your your classmates your teammates uh
been integral to your team winning
victory over somebody else
you've enjoyed that sort of pleasures
you have experience with that
you've all you know enjoyed eating and
drinking right
that sort of bodily pleasure stuff like
taking naps
you know playing video games watching tv
that sort of stuff that's enjoyable
so who actually has the the most
experience
plato says well this guy
the person who's devoted to this kind of
life they know what bodily pleasures are
like because we all pursue bodily
pleasures
you could of course have somebody who's
like the prototypical nerd
uh as opposed you know there's
oftentimes intellectual people make a
distinction between a nerd and a geek
have you guys ever heard this
distinction nerds are lacking social
skills
and they're intensely interested in
something and vaguely intellectual
geeks are intensely interested in that
but they actually have social skills
they know how to get along with other
people
so it's an insult to be called a nerd
but it's a good thing to be a geek
familiar with this now you know um
but you could have somebody who's very
nerdy
and doesn't know what physical pleasures
are like or doesn't appreciate them
couldn't you
plato's not talking about that kind of
guy clayton's talking about somebody
who actually has experienced physical
pleasures
now people who are good at what they do
intellectually
do they get to experience things like
this
honor respect what's a good question for
our society
um
you know if you make a million out of it
then we we tend to honor you but if
you're just you know
some some guy who's written a book about
something maybe not
but plato in his time at least you could
say yeah generally you know they're
looked up to for
for you know what they've achieved i'll
tell you with philosophy
with my family because i come from a
blue collar background
i had a hell of a time um
explaining to them why what i did was
not just a complete waste of time
you know they asked things like what is
it you produce exactly
you're gonna write a book you because
okay so you teach students but what are
you teaching them
what's this philosophy business this is
the things like
well i teach them how to read texts well
hell
can't they just read text on their own i
mean go buy a book
you know there's lack of understanding
so lack of
appreciation we can actually call
appreciation this sort of thing
just assume for a moment that the
philosopher
the intellectual actually does get this
so they have experience of all three
pleasures
the question is do these guys
have experience of all three pleasures
all your life is about
making money and then enjoying yourself
are you going to likely spend a lot of
time
learning you'll learn so you can get the
mba
so you can get the job but in your spare
time are you going to spend your time
learning
probably not what if you're very
ambitious
learning you'll learn the things that
you need in order to get ahead
in order to like say gain office or be
in charge
but you're probably not going to spend a
lot of time learning for its own sex
you're not going to experience that
pleasure
so the people who run their lives
according to these parts of the soul
are not going to be as good of a judge
about the
the type of pleasure that we're talking
about the quality of the pleasure
what about what he's calling the
criteria let me talk about a criterion
what does that mean
criterion for something
we usually say criteria right yeah
yeah i think we do use the word in that
way uh
yeah like a rubric like a general
guideline almost
yeah okay that's a good way to put it
too criteria show up in rubrics right
because rubrics are like this
big complicated uh document that we put
together
we give like i give you criteria for
what i want to see in your
papers those those are like requirements
and
this is what counts as a great paper is
what counts as a social paper
a criterion is a means of judging it's
what you use to
make a judgment so what is the criterion
that's used by the intellectual it's
reason itself
that's really the best criterion you're
not going to get much better than that
faculty of reason this guy
is going to use the criteria does it
lead to
honor respect appreciation being in
charge
success victory that can be a good
criterion in a lot of respects can't it
if you're being pragmatic about things
and say what's actually going to work
we need to win games what's actually
going to help us win
games there's your criteria right we
need to
get this report done before our
competitors come out with a new product
so that we can beat them out in the
market that's that's a criterion right
is that going to work for everything
that's valuable in your life
can you treat say your relationship with
your significant other that way
you know what's going to bring you honor
respect prestige
pride should i date her or shouldn't i
i don't know is she going to bring me
prestige
how does that sound to you maybe it
doesn't
work so well for that should i
actually study plato for the sake of
studying plato i don't know
is it going to lead to success over my
opponents
probably not well i'm not going to play
with that you're going to miss out on
some stuff
then by doing that so that's not going
to be that reliable of a criterion
in some ways it's still a better
criterion than at this level because
what does this person rely on
is it going to make me money it's not
going to make me money it's not worth
anything
now imagine putting relationships in
that sort of
framework you know
you know to think about teaching for
example
this is not particularly remunitive
maybe i should just you know like have
you guys
you know watch a bunch of uh movies
and uh make things totally easy for
myself
and uh just kind of phone it in
you know would that be the right thing
to do
you're wrong in many respects wouldn't
it um you
you should get angry you know the very
notion of that i think
um but if all that counts for me is
making a lot of money that would make
sense is my criteria
there's going to be a lot more left out
in the pursuit of wealth
and the valuation of wealth is the
primary good or even the pleasures it
brings
then there will be using the faculty of
reason the person who has reason can
appreciate how how good wealth is it's
but it's a limited good right it's not
the good
it's it's good for something bringing
pleasure and pleasures are good
but it's not the good so
who's the best qualified person well
what's the answer we're supposed to
arrive at
or the person who devotes themselves to
cultivating
this part of their soul which means that
these parts are gonna have to be in line
because if you're too ambitious this
part of your soul is going to make
reason do what it wants
if you can't control your appetites
you're not going to have time to you
know develop reason very much
you're just going to use reason to
satisfy your appetites and you're at
risk for becoming a
tyrannical person if you don't develop
some some limits
so that is um how plato resolves this
i don't know how do you guys find this
plausible or is there some holes in this
i pointed out a few
but this you know this is his model this
is his idea
one of the things that's worth you know
carrying forth from this is this notion
that
even the rational part has its desires
and its distinctive pleasures
it's not supposed to be you know a
really boring life that he's advocating
he has one of the things that he says
that's kind of interesting about these
pleasures as well
and here he gets very metaphysical
he starts talking about the nature of
pain and pleasure
you probably haven't thought that much
about this but next week we're actually
going to talk
much more about this um
these are opposites right
pain and pleasure but not the same thing
clearly yeah
now is it is it sort of like an on off
switch
like that light switch over there where
you're either feeling pain or you're
feeling pleasure
and you know one or the other or is
there something that involves like a
middle
a neutral state in between
let's move this a little bit more so
it's a bit more symmetrical
um
state of rest neither pain nor pleasure
doesn't this seem more plausible to you
now
think about certain pains that you have
experienced
in your lifetime that plato talks about
in this test
being sick all of you have probably been
pretty sick in the last year at one time
or another
um and if you haven't been like you know
sick because of illness maybe you've
been hungover
you know that that's better than being
sick with illness because it goes away
pretty quick right
but um when you're sick
just being not sick feels so good
and you desire it so much because the
pain really sucks
right and you have a terrible headache
the headache goes away and you're like
man
it's a great day now so you don't always
have to go all the way over
here to feel pleasure
pleasure can come about from a removal
or a lessening or a privation
of pain
hunger is like that when you're really
hungry it hurts right
yeah you felt hunger pangs in your in
your stomach
and you go and you get something to eat
you don't even care what it is i mean
you need like you know
crappiest food whatsoever if you're
really hungry and you'll think wow
this is excellent and then about like
five minutes later when you're fully
like i can't believe i ate that that
garbage but
you know why does it feel so good they
say hunger is the best sauce
because you move from a condition of
pain to a condition of no longer having
the pain and it feels
pleasurable in the process so
there is a kind of
pleasure that comes from it what about
can it work the other way around
take away a pleasure that you're feeling
particularly intensely
and now you feel pain as a result
think about when you're really into
here's a great example
somebody's playing a game right they're
just about to beat that level
and then suddenly the power goes out
what's their reaction
they throw the controller start swearing
you know stupid electric company
now you know a more rational approach
would be trying to figure out the
diffuse blow
you know that's where people we have
this reaction at first why
because we feel like a kind of uh
pain as a result of pleasure being taken
away
um you ever try to stop a dog eating
when it's when it's
eating it's meal probably only try it
once and the dog will probably try to
bite you
because uh they they're really enjoying
that
um people do that too you know
what else do we have other phantom pains
like that we i mean we have that with
with uh
sexual things stop somebody right in the
middle of everything and pleasure
turns to pain um
drinking somebody cuts you up at the bar
now you're
irritated it's not a fun night anymore i
guess that could
count as that sort of thing um now
here's where it gets interesting plato
talks about
he says you have to imagine a world in
which there's
a higher and a middle
and a lower level
and let's say that you've
only lived in this lower level your
entire life
you don't actually know that there's a
higher level
you go from the lower to the middle
level what are you going to think the
middle level is
yeah exactly so you're going to think
that this is
actually higher and are you right about
that
you're wrong about that right but it's
because you don't actually know
better you haven't experienced the
higher level
i think we can apply this to a lot of
different sort of things um
people are you know like learning about
something that they they just
didn't it didn't occur to them before um
people have all these sort of
interesting realizations now can that
can that apply to this
well these things in between
are sort of like somebody going from the
lower level
up to the middle level or you could go
the other way around right you could go
from the
higher level down to the middle level
and then what will the middle level look
like it'll look like the lower level
right it's an illusion so
there's all sorts of things that we
think are pleasures
and think our pains that aren't really
when they come down to it pleasures and
pains in any genuine sense they're only
in appearance this is why i said it's
kind of metaphysical right
reality and appearance um
now most bodily pleasures
when you boil down to it are oftentimes
a result of going from a state of
you know lacking something or something
bothering us to that being taken away
or getting what it is that you want
right
think about the pleasure that the attic
feels
as opposed to the pleasure that the
first time
user feels when it comes to various
drugs or even you know
smoking or drinking i remember when i
first started smoking
i smoked for years after you get past
like the
coughing and that sort of thing that
feeling of your lungs like contracting
in on you it's kind of a rush
after a while you don't get that anymore
but you need the cigarette
and you can't start your day without it
if you don't have it
you're going to feel pain and then when
you do get it it's not like you're
actually
feeling pleasure as such you're just not
feeling
pain and you're like yeah this is really
good um
that's the way coffee is for me now i
drink about two pots a day which is not
good
i don't advise that uh and if i don't if
i don't drink coffee
i'll do these terrible headaches a lot
of pain
the drinking the coffee it's pleasurable
but it's not super pleasurable it's not
way over here
it's more satisfying and need that i
have
now plato thinks that most of our bodily
pleasures are that kind
what about um other kinds of pleasures
he doesn't talk about like the pleasures
of
winning or
success but i think you could say that
those are very often
that sort of thing as well what about
learning
when you don't know something beforehand
do you feel pain in your head
where that empty spot with learning a
lot to be
no then when you actually do learn
something it's just kind of this
innocent pleasure right
it's generally not going to get you in
trouble unless you're learning something
that's mostly
i'm not applying it so the the kind of
pleasure that's available
through higher things is
is a more real more
genuine pleasure and that's only
available to the person who cultivates
their faculty
of reason it's not available to the
person who just cultivates their
their appetites or their spirited part
of their soul
in order to truly be happy in order to
truly experience pleasure playing what
i'm saying
you have to cultivate your your rational
part of your soul
so in order to be truly happy you would
actually have to be
just that's where this leads to
what that implies is that we're not
actually once we're completely just i
know i'm not
we're not actually as happy as we could
so that's a good point to sort of end on
and think about